6000 m² de laboratoires et mitec a vu
grand pour mener au mieux ces tests dans
la certification et la mise au point des
produits dans les domaines grand public
aéronautique et médicales les nouveaux
locaux à montigny le bretonneux met les
150 salariés dans les meilleures
dispositions pour mener des essais de
résistance aux chocs secoue ses
vibrations
ce sont des locaux dans lequel au même
endroit à un client peut faire
l'ensemble des essais que je ai dit
compatibilité électromagnétique et c'est
donc c'est extrêmement important
c'est un lieu unique au auquel le client
peut réaliser l'ensemble de ses besoins
des scènes des essais menés notamment
sur la capacité des matériaux à résister
au feu dont les avions
pourquoi on génère congénères un
ensemble et un air carburant
la partie supérieure du matériel est un
matériel qui va être soit un plancher
soit un plafond on intervient aux lèvres
la résistance des matériaux qui sont mis
en oeuvre
elles doivent assurer effectivement la
capacité d'une part d'auto extinction
une capacité de résistance est
évidemment une capacité dans le pire des
cas d'évacuation dans ses laboratoires
emitech peut également recréer les
vibrations d'un trajet quotidien qu'ils
soient routiers ferroviaires ou aériens
là c'est pour approcher un petit peu
c'est pas si vous voyez on voit vraiment
comment se défendre la règle cette
france là donc on va avoir c'est
effectivement subissant ces vibrations
on va parler des dégradations des noms
fond de réalité qui pourrait être
critique pour le fonctionnement
d'ailleurs à partir des essais menés
comme sur ces câblage de véhicules à qui
l'on a fait subir des perturbations un
rapport est transmis aux clients qui
décidera avec les autorités et de la
mise en équipement des appareils
en fait c est fait donc en pré
qualification et qualification pour pour
qu'une fois qu'il est monté sur le
véhicule qui est que le client n'ait pas
d'impact sur l'utilisation du véhicule
emitech travaille avec des grands
groupes comme safran valeo et thales
l'entreprise enregistre chaque année une
croissance de 10%